this male bonobo chimpanzee may look
like a dominant male but he's really
just a big mama's boy that's because in
bonobo society the Mamas hold lots of
power it's shared between males and
females
this alpha female is one of the group's
leaders don't believe it
watch how she snaps the sapling then
struts her stuff in a way that would
make any dominant male chimpanzee proud
the message is clear this babe is boss
these bossy adult females form strong
bonds with their offspring especially
the males all babies are intimately
cared for through the first five years
but eventually young female bonobos must
leave the truth and find another troop
to accept them the sons stay behind and
the ones with the most powerful mothers
become the most privileged males bonobo
mother's almost never discipline their
young even when they steal food right
out of Mom's mouth